but anyway i'm kidding dude i think
you're good i don't know what i'm
talking about and i apologize for that
i'm tired
i'm grumpy so i apologize that you're
none of that
it's okay and i want to say thank you so
much um for
being a part of my life thank you so
much for being here
and being so supportive over the years
and you know what the first time i ever
met you
i didn't like you but it it instant but
it took a couple of weeks and
instantaneously he
seeped into my soul he's so different
now there are parts of you
i do miss like what um
i think you used to be a lot more
playful and reachable i respect you
no no you used to respect me so much you
should be so nervous around me
no i'll say that i was you know when you
were like you didn't like me
i was like well me clown are like we're
like i love like our relationship and i
was like man bobby [ __ ] hates me that
was a time in my life too where
my um i wanted to like get everyone's
affirmation
so at that point in my life when you
were doing that [ __ ] yeah well that was
not good i just didn't know what whims i
wish i had better very i wish i had
betterhelp.com honestly
i didn't know if you were i didn't know
who you were i don't know who brought
you over to my house oh why
why you don't get you don't take time to
get to know people
the first time he came to the house i
never said
to whoever who brought you jenna me no
her
all right so you never i never all right
whatever i didn't ask you it's a ufc
fight you never came up to me and said
you never came up to me and says hey
this whimsical fairy
this whimsical fairy is gonna prance
around the house eventually you know i
mean so just be aware no
i'm sitting there and all of a sudden
whimsical fairy flies into the [ __ ]
room and then i'm like
who the [ __ ] is that guy um you know i
need some warning when whimsical fairies
come into my house
hmm i miss those early days yeah me too
gilbert hollywood he's a little
hollywood i will say that you are
hollywood i will say i'm less hollywood
i will say
so that's no holly would have used it
because here's here's why yeah that was
so hollywood of you saying that
to do people people go like that is so
hollywood no no
all right then why but i'll give you
this it was both hollywood
both our responses were hollywood but uh
fine but the most hollywood yeah
who's the most hollywood in the room
who's wait who's grown ends
exponentially from zero hollywood to a
little more hollywood yeah
don't you dare you look this direction
that's not true i am the
least hollywood we were trying to stop
we were able you're
[ __ ] you were babe i have to say it
i'm just so glad you brought it up
because she was zero so glad i'm not
even saying she's hollywood i'm not even
saying you're hollywood now so hollywood
i wouldn't say i have not one hollywood
friend oh yeah
where were you last night david spade's
house right that's hollywood
oh that's hollywood that's not hollywood
what is that
okay casual just because somebody that
lives in hollywood
all right first of all this just because
someone lives in hollywood
and works in hollywood doesn't make them
hollywood it's their mentality and the
way they behave
all right so i walked into david spade's
house right
and he goes i ordered your food
i go okay did you you got the prosciutto
i asked him caesar all the stuff he goes
yeah all right relax i got it
so the food comes right and this is
how on hollywood i am okay
this is how on halloween they opened up
the boxes
and only my food was in it like whoever
delivered it forgot to
put in all the other only my stuff came
that's
right so then to see a kyle dunnigan was
there too right
and so to see kyle and dave just kind of
look at me and i go
you know what let's share
that's not hollywood that makes you
unhollywood is sharing not only do that
i didn't make the assumption that dave
was going to pay for it so i i had a
couple hundred bucks i go
you need some money right he goes no man
i got it
right so that's not a hollywood it to
show money what makes someone hollywood
how do we define that i i have one
definition i share one very clear
definition
go ahead they never pick up phone calls
on the first go
hmm that doesn't make anyone happy yeah
that's crazy i know regular people that
do that no because gilbert and you
never [ __ ] pick up phone calls
because i'm around me because i'm doing
other things but i call them
i call back immediately when i'm done no
you don't yeah i do it takes you like
a day and a half this is the nutshell of
what i think hollywood they
fundamentally believe deep down inside
that they're
better than the common folk
yeah but they do this thing where they
pretend like they're trying to be
like humble and cool and dressed like
homeless
or whatever i don't have friends i mean
i have my friends you know what you're
doing you know what you're doing right
now
okay and i don't want to start a fight
i'm competing this is a podcast i don't
want to start a fight but i just want to
call you because
gilbert brought it up okay call me out
it's just that you're doing this thing
where it's like you wrote this great
show
can we oh my god no okay i'd like to
clarify
number one uh not so it has not been
sold
has not been pitched and there is
nothing it's it's literally
all right so she's like how is that even
i'll tell you why it's not a thing no no
because pretty she okay
i had to [ __ ] ease my way into this
all right but it's like
she'll do things like she'll call me and
go you know um
wants to be involved i don't know if i
[Laughter]
and i go and just by her calling is
hollywood because she knows
that it is a big deal i don't know yeah
yeah it's a big deal
right because she just mentioned the one
of the biggest agents
i didn't know that i didn't know that
i'm telling you i'll say one of the
biggest agents i don't even know who
that is
exactly i don't know spielberg i'm not
hollywood like you i don't know
we're not hollywood enough to know that
all right so what i'm saying though is
that
for you to because you're you're calling
me
because you you know that it sounds oh
just keep
bleeping out that [ __ ] name um and i
called you not for that i called you to
say
hollywood baby no it's not yeah and you
do things like you
you outwardly say like i'm not hollywood
and i don't say it yeah
by you saying that you're not hollywood
it makes you hollywood
okay well how about restaurant are there
things you can do in a restaurant that
makes you hollywood
yeah would you thinking that you have
preferential and i don't i wait i've
waited so you've been around me where
i've
waited so long i'll sit there and wait
forever for a table
even until they close no but i have oh
wow and now
and i'll even complain about it we got
into this massive fight at the vaccine
site
yeah we already talked sounds like a
sitcom no we haven't there's something
in my eye though um
now we had into this massive fight
because i was like can you look a little
less bobby lee
what does that mean he just was like you
know the beanie and the thing and the
sunglasses he was so reckoned and and i
was just like yeah like
okay i want to say something okay can i
be me
damn that's a can i beat me 24 7.
that's my that's my motto me 24 7.
that's what i want to be
i just didn't want him to use it as
another i wear my beanie i don't feel
comfortable without
one right i wear my gooches
gucci because i don't feel comfortable
i'm wearing a mask
correct yeah i think that's suffice and
you know what he said he was like
no one's gonna know who i am with a mask
on
and sure enough like the first as soon
as we like parked
the first thing is the guy was like
anywho you're hollywood
you're hollywood and you're not that
hollywood and this is the most
no his hair is like that's a director
look dude
emo phillips like you know he he's
emotional do you remember emo phillips
no
you don't know emo phil hopes he pull it
up he he's got that vibe he's got emo
phillips's vibe
oh yeah yeah yeah just a general
like you know in peewee's playhouse he
would be
popping